Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Nous sommes le 11 août 2024.
Il est 8 h 57 à Paris.
Le soleil est déjà haut dans le ciel.
Il fait bon, mais j'ai
le cœur qui bat vite.
J’ai les jambes qui trépignent.
Je suis serrée. On me marche dessus.
Je fais des petits sauts sur place
pour garder mes pulsations hautes.
Je suis habillée en bleu, blanc rouge.
Je porte le dossard 108 dans le dos.
À l’avant est inscrit mon nom
de famille en majuscules.
J'ai de la chance d'être ici.
Je pense à ma famille, à mes amis,
à mon entraîneur.
J'ai envie qu'ils soient fiers de moi.
J'ai envie d'y arriver.
Mais j’ai peur, je stresse,
j’ai comme une boule dans le ventre,
il faut que je reprenne
une respiration plus lente.
J’inspire profondément
et je souffle doucement.
Je pense à mon frère
qui, lui, me regarde du ciel.
Je me répète doucement :
« Tu peux le faire. Tu vas y arriver. »
Il est maintenant 8 h 59
et, dans une minute,
retentira le coup de pistolet du départ
du marathon des Jeux Olympiques.
(Voix en anglais : Une minute.)
Je me mets en position, le bras droit
et la jambe gauche devant.
Je fixe un point lointain ;
je suis déterminée.
(Voix en anglais : Trente secondes.)
Une dernière grande inspiration.
(Inspire)
(Bruit de réveil)
Bon, on n’en est pas encore là.
Je m’appelle Mathilde Sénéchal
et je suis sportive de haut niveau
en équipe de France d’athlétisme.
Mon rêve, c'est de participer au marathon
des Jeux Olympiques à Paris en 2024.
Ouais, rien que ça.
Vous vous demandez peut-être ce qui
est arrivée à cette petite fille
pour qu’un jour elle se mette
à rêver des Jeux Olympiques.
Eh bien, je vous propose d’embarquer
avec moi dans cette aventure
où chacun pourra s’identifier,
puisqu’en réalité
nous avons tous des rêves,
des objectifs à notre mesure
que nous voulons atteindre.
Mais comment faire pour passer
du rêve à la réalité ?
Et que se passe-t-il
si nous n’y arrivons pas ?
Tout commence par s’autoriser à rêver.
Il faut avoir suffisamment d’estime
et de confiance en soi
pour se permettre d’avoir des rêves,
des objectifs importants.
Au départ, je n'aurais jamais pensé un
jour vouloir faire les Jeux Olympiques.
Cela me paraissait trop grand,
trop fort, trop dur pour moi.
Mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi se mettre des barrières
et des limites avant même de commencer ?
Le premier pas vers son rêve,
c’est de s’autoriser à en avoir un.
Si on se permet de rêver,
alors peut-être...
Au départ, rien ne me destinait
à être une athlète de haut niveau.
Mes parents sont sportifs mais ne
m’ont jamais poussée à en être une.
Les études, c'était le plus important.
J’ai commencé l’athlétisme
assez tardivement, en 2012.
Mon professeur de sport au collège
m’a repérée
car j’étais la seule fille arrivant
à suivre les garçons en course à pied.
Il m’a proposé de rejoindre l’équipe UNSS
pour représenter le collège
lors des différents cross.
Encouragée par mon père, j’ai accepté.
Je me suis fait ensuite repérer
par mon club à Blois,
dans lequel je suis toujours
licenciée aujourd’hui.
Le dimanche 15 janvier 2012, je me
suis présentée pour la première fois
sur le cross départemental
sous les couleurs de mon nouveau club.
Je ne savais pas à quoi m’attendre.
J’appréhendais.
Et pourtant, aussi inattendu
que ce soit, je gagne cette course.
Et ça, c’est le début
d’une grande aventure.
Partie sur cette bonne lancée,
j’ai ensuite continué les compétitions
au niveau régional et inter-régional.
Un an après, en 2013,
je décroche le titre de championne
de France scolaire à Caen.
Pour s'autoriser de rêver, il faut se
connaître, savoir à quoi l'on aspire.
Au fond, je pense que j’ai toujours eu
en moi l’âme d’une compétitrice.
Depuis toute petite, j’aime gagner, être
la première à l’école ou dans le sport.
On a tous en nous
un trait de caractère particulier,
une appétence singulière pour un domaine,
une matière, un talent à identifier.
Même si parfois ce sont
les autres qui le voient.
Pour ma part, ce sont
les paroles de mon entraîneur
qui m’ont permis de me dire
qu’un jour, peut-être,
je pourrai espérer représenter la France
sur la plus grande compétition mondiale.
Selon lui, j'ai les capacités
pour y prétendre.
Il a éveillé en moi une flamme
que je n'osais allumer.
J’avais peur que l’on se moque, que l’on
pense que j’étais trop prétentieuse
ou tout bonnement à côté de la plaque.
Mais en réalité, avoir un rêve
aussi fort que les Jeux Olympiques
me permet d’élever mon niveau
d’exigence au quotidien.
C’est parce que je me suis fixé
un objectif très dur
que je vais redoubler
d’efforts pour l’atteindre.
Oser viser haut.
Peu importe le résultat,
je serai sortie de ma zone de confort
et j’atterrirai plus loin
que ce que je n’espérais.
Bon, c’est vrai qu’au début,
c’était facile pour moi :
je n’étais pas connue de mes concurrentes,
j’avais ce qu’on appelle le rôle
d’outsider dans le jargon.
Je me présentais sur les courses
avec envie et légèreté et ça marchait.
Championne départementale, régionale,
je me suis ensuite qualifiée
au championnat de France de cross.
Cette année-là, j’ai terminé 11e.
Mon coach m’avait dit : « Bon,
l’année prochaine, on visera le podium. »
Malheureusement, le sport,
ce n’est pas que des mathématiques.
Nous sommes en 2015.
Je ne suis plus une outsider.
Je fais maintenant partie des favorites
et je dois l’assumer.
J’ai comme ambition
de gagner le championnat
de France de cross dans ma catégorie.
Je me suis bien entraînée, je suis prête.
Comme à chaque fois avec mon équipe,
nous avons repéré le parcours la veille.
J’ai croisé quelques concurrentes
et l’une d’elles m’a dit :
« Bon, c’est facile pour toi,
on sait demain que tu vas gagner. »
Le jour J, nous sommes 300
à nous présenter sur ligne de départ.
Il y a environ six kilomètres à parcourir.
Je pars aux avant-postes.
Je me sens bien.
Je mène les premiers kilomètres.
À à peine la moitié de la course,
deux concurrentes me dépassent,
de seulement quelques mètres.
Et pourtant, à ce moment précis,
je sens mes jambes s’alourdir, se raidir.
Ma cage thoracique semble réduire de
volume. Je ne sais pas ce qu’il m’arrive.
Je ne comprends pas ce qu’il se passe.
Ça ne m’avait jamais fait ça auparavant.
J’essaye d’avancer, mais j’ai
les jambes de plus en plus lourdes.
La respiration est de plus
en plus difficile.
Les encouragements sur le côté deviennent
des bruits assourdissants
Des concurrentes qui ne m’avaient jamais
battue auparavant me dépassent.
J'essaye de m'accrocher tant bien que mal.
À quelques centaines
de mètres de l’arrivée,
je m’écroule sur les barrières
qui délimitent le parcours.
Mes coéquipières me doublent
en se demandant ce qu’il m’arrive.
Ce que je vais vous raconter
à partir de ce moment,
c’est ce qu’on m’a raconté
puisque moi j’ai fait un total black-out
de ce qui s’est passé.
J'étais devenue complètement inconsciente.
Il y a donc une de mes coéquipières,
la dernière de mon équipe,
qui s’est arrêtée
pour me ramasser, littéralement.
Elle a mis mon bras sur son épaule
et m’a aidée à franchir les dernières
centaines de mètres qu’il nous restait.
Elle m’a balancée sur la ligne d’arrivée
pour que mon dossard valide ma place
et que mon chrono s’arrête.
Je visais le podium.
Je suis 168e.
Nous avions également
des objectifs par équipe.
Alors qu’il fallait ramener le plus petit
score possible en fonction de notre place,
je ramène 168 points.
Autant dire que c'était foutu.
Je suis emmenée dans la tente de secours
où on me met sous perfusion.
Ma mère, infirmière, est à mes côtés.
J’ai la boule au ventre
de retrouver mes coéquipières.
Je suis déçue de moi-même
et j’ai déçu les autres.
J’ai envie de disparaître dans un trou.
J’ai honte.
Bref, le rêve qui se transforme
en cauchemar.
Alors comment on fait à 17 ans
pour affronter cet échec ?
Eh bien moi, je me suis fait aider.
Je me suis retrouvée dans le bureau
de ce qu’on appelle préparateur mental,
ce qui se faisait très peu à l’époque.
Nous avons travaillé pour comprendre
ce qui mentalement
m'avait fait perdre cette course.
Ce n’est pas une honte
de demander de l’aide.
Parfois, on ne peut pas tout
gérer seul et c'est OK.
Je pense qu’on a tous besoin
d’une sorte de psy à nos côtés
pour entretenir notre santé mentale.
Grâce à ce travail,
aujourd’hui, je ne vois plus cette course
comme un échec, mais comme une expérience.
D’ailleurs, on dit que l’on n’apprend bien
plus de nos échecs que de nos victoires.
Et c'est vrai.
La puissance du rêve permet
de surmonter l'échec.
C’est un objectif si fort
que l’on continue de s’accrocher
malgré les difficultés.
On tombe et on se relève.
Deux ans plus tard, je suis devenue
championne de France de cross.
Nous voilà maintenant en 2017.
Après une saison quasi-parfaite,
je me qualifie pour la première fois aux
championnats d’Europe sur le 3000 mètres.
Nous sommes à Grosseto, en Italie.
Ma course est en fin de journée. Je
n’ai pas le meilleur chrono des engagées.
Je me dis qu'un top dix serait bien,
un top cinq serait super.
Je suis sur la ligne de départ
et je souris.
Je souris car je suis heureuse d’être là.
C'était mon objectif de me qualifier
pour cette course.
Le départ est donné.
Nous avons sept tours et demi à parcourir.
Je suis en milieu de peloton.
Je me focalise sur mes allures.
Je garde toujours en vision
la tête de course.
Plus les tours passent, plus je
commence à gagner des places.
Je passe sixième, cinquième, quatrième.
Le podium devient alors accessible,
mais je ne m'en rends pas compte.
Je me laisse porter.
Je sens que je suis bien, alors j’y vais.
Je dépasse la troisième.
Les yeux rivés sur la tête de course,
à quelques mètres devant.
Malgré mes efforts, les deux premières
maintiennent l'écart.
Je relance.
À 250 mètres de la ligne d’arrivée,
la deuxième craque et je la dépasse.
Je donne tout ce que j'ai pour
garder cette place inespérée.
Il me reste encore des forces
pour relancer les 50 derniers mètres.
Je souris.
Je lève le bras.
Je comprends ce qui est
en train de se passer.
Je suis vice-championne d’Europe.
Vous vous souvenez, au début, je vous
parlais du fait de s'autoriser à rêver.
Eh bien moi, c’est à partir
de ce moment précis
que j’ai commencé
à rêver encore plus grand.
Plus grand que les championnats de France,
que les championnats d’Europe,
j’ai commencé à rêver des Jeux Olympiques.
Et maintenant, où j’en suis ?
Comment on construit dans le présent
son objectif du futur ?
Il reste 496 jours
avant les Jeux olympiques de Paris.
Je m’entraîne tous les jours le matin
et le soir pour devenir meilleure.
Je cours entre 3000 et 4000 kilomètres
par an, soit la distance de Paris à Dakar.
Mon quotidien est entièrement tourné
vers la réussite de mon objectif.
Tout doit servir à cela.
Je fais attention à mon sommeil,
à mon alimentation.
Mon corps est mon outil de travail,
je dois l’écouter pour ne pas me blesser.
Cela induit de nombreuses heures de
renforcement musculaire et de soins.
La blessure, c'est la hantise du sportif.
On a toujours cette épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête,
cette part d’impondérable
dans la réussite de notre objectif.
Mais c'est aussi ce qui fait
la beauté du rêve.
On ne sait pas si on va y arriver,
si on va l’atteindre,
car beaucoup de paramètres
peuvent interférer.
Il y a quelques mois, je suis partie
en stage au Kenya,
au pays de la course à pied,
pendant trois semaines.
Je me suis blessée
au bout du cinquième jour.
J’ai alors dû m’entraîner sur le vélo,
à la salle de sport,
pendant que tous mes autres
coéquipiers partaient courir.
J’ai dû m’adapter, changer les plans,
trouver un nouveau chemin,
toujours dans l’optique d’atteindre
mon rêve, mon objectif principal.
L'adaptation est indispensable
pour rebondir.
Le sportif de haut niveau doit
aussi sans cesse se dépasser.
Il faut s’entraîner plus dur,
aller plus vite, tenir plus longtemps.
Se dépasser, c’est aller
au-delà de soi-même,
aller là où on ne s’en
sentait pas capable.
Et le rêve est un incroyable
moteur pour cela.
Il y a aussi beaucoup
de remises en question.
Après tout, je ne sais même pas
si je vais y arriver.
Je me demande si ça vaut le coup.
Il y a des jours où je ne suis pas
motivée pour m’entraîner.
Je n’ai pas envie de courir dans
le froid, le vent ou sous la pluie.
La discipline prend alors
le relais et j'y vais.
C’est aussi ça, se dépasser.
Mais finalement, pourquoi ce rêve ?
Peut-être simplement
pour se sentir vivante.
Personnellement, il n’y a pas un instant
où je me sens plus en vie et ancrée dans
l’instant présent que lorsque je cours.
C'est ce qui me fait vibrer.
Je suis sûre que vous l’avez vous aussi,
cette activité, cette passion, ce moment
où vous vous sentez pleinement en vie.
Bon.
J’irai aux Jeux Olympiques ou pas ?
Je vais le réaliser ce rêve, oui ou non ?
Ben en fait, peu importe.
Attendez.
Elle nous a fait tout son speech
sur la puissance du rêve
pour nous dire que
finalement elle s’en fiche ?
Pas vraiment !
Ce que je veux dire, c’est que ce n’est
pas la réalisation de cet objectif
qui fera de moi une femme
plus heureuse ou plus accomplie.
Vous l’aurez compris,
cela aura été un voyage incroyable,
digne d’un marathon avant d’espérer
atteindre celui des Jeux Olympiques.
Ce sont les victoires,
les échecs, les rencontres,
qui feront que cette aventure
aura été unique.
Pas forcément le point d'arrivée.
Mais si j’y crois et que
je me donne les moyens,
comme dirait un journaliste bien
connu du milieu sportif,
alors peut-être...
Je suis reconnaissante envers tous ceux
qui m’accompagnent dans cette aventure.
Derrière la réussite
apparemment individuelle
se cache en réalité
une multitude de personnes.
Des piliers, des partenaires.
Et l'aventure a bien plus de valeur
lorsqu'elle est partagée.
Maintenant, vous faites aussi
partie de mon chemin.
Je pense que l’on fait
tous partie de l’histoire des autres.
Nous avons tous nos propres chemins,
mais il arrive parfois que deux chemins se
croisent le temps d’une après-midi,
où se rejoignent le temps
de quelques années.
Profitons de ce voyage,
admirons les paysages,
savourons les petits pas en avant
et même ceux où l’on recule.
Soyons reconnaissants
pour ceux qui nous accompagnent
et continuons de rêver ensemble.
Bon, je crois qu'on vous attend.
Vous êtes maintenant prêt à arpenter le
chemin de vos rêves, quels qu'ils soient.
N'ayez pas peur.
Osez rêver en grand.
Je vous souhaite donc un excellent voyage.
(Applaudissements)